merci pour cette excellente introduction
à un moment dans la soirée ou et
commence à faire tard il est vrai où
effectivement on vient de manger et de
boire et certains ne se sont pas
limitées au coca cola j'ai vu alors rien
que pour vous être agréable
je vais vous faire faire parce qu'on va
écouter des choses un peu difficiles il
ya de la science donc dur mais j'ai une
gêne à k1 k2 l'écoutent des choses
difficiles alors je sais que tout de
suite vous dans votre fauteuil
surtout pas moi surtout pas moi mais ne
vous inquiétez pas ce sera sans douleur
est le plus difficile dans ces cas là
c'est toujours le premier pas alors pour
que votre attention soit au top pendant
tout mon discours je vais vous demander
d'un seul homme de vous lever
s'il vous plaît oh vous êtes merveilleux
merci beaucoup
alors vous allez faire comme moi et sur
le dernier geste tout à l'heure il y
aura du texte le texte c'est quoi
après moi quoi super alors les
mouvements avec moi 1 2 3 et 1 2 3 1
on combat en fait maintenant quoi quoi
quoi quoi quoi 1,2 kw à 1 et 2 et quoi à
1 et 2 et quoi a et e et quoi a et e et
quoi à et de est quoi un et deux et quoi
ok et vous saurez
merci pour cette participation super
alors effectivement je vais vous parler
des effets de la danse sur le corps et
sur le cerveau mais je ne suis pas un
intermittent du spectacle un peu
désoeuvrés je suis effectivement
neurobiologiste et c'est un sujet que je
montre très au sérieux mais c'est un
sujet qui m'est venu progressivement
c'est pas partie d'une histoire
théorique mais d'une histoire très très
pratique il ya quelques temps mais je
travaillais dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique et pendant cette époque
envoyons un petit peu comment ça
fonctionnait j'étais de plus en plus
étonné de voir que notre société soit
aussi complaisante pour payer des
traitements de maladies qui ne devraient
même pas exister des maladies de longue
durée comme on dit comme le diabète de
type 2 comme les maladies
cardiovasculaires certains cancers
alors figurez vous que dans l'union
européenne
nous dépensons tous les ont 700
milliards d'euros juste pour traiter ces
maladies là ça ne prend même pas en
compte les arrêts maladie la baisse de
productivité
l'absentéisme le présentéisme juste pour
le traitement
tous les ans c'est plus qu'on dépense
pour tous les systèmes de l'éducation
réunis alors je me suis demandé comment
ça se fait qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
alors tout le monde sait ce qu'il faut
faire en réalité il faut bouger plus
vous mangez moi il faut bouger plus et
donc pourquoi on ne le fait pas c'est
tellement évident c'est tellement simple
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne le fait pas
alors je vois tout de suite là dans le
public y en a certains qui ont la tête
bien haute savoie mais moi je le fais
tous les matins je me lève à 5 heures et
je fais mon jogging mais calmez vous
je suis désolé de vous apprendre qu'on
fait ça ne vous fait pas plus de bien
pour notre problème que des gens qui ne
font pas de sport parce que le système
de santé britannique la nhs à regarder
de près ce problème parce qu'ils sont
très soucieux d une grande dépense et
ils ont fait une méta-analyse de tout ce
qui existe sur le rapport entre
l'activité physique et les maladies ces
fameuses maladie de longue durée et il
les résultats qui concernent est quand
même plus de 800000 personnes nous
apprennent une chose assez incroyable
c'est que pour des menus diminuer le
risque de ces maladies
il faut se lever une fois par heure et
bouger pendant une à deux minutes
c'était ça la conclusion de leurs
travaux alors c'est énorme ça c'est
quand même bizarre ça correspond pas du
tout à ce qu'on nous dit depuis des
années ne paye le guen il faut
transpirer y faut avoir le taux
cardiaque à 4 remboursant de ce qu'il
peut faire et c'est non apparemment
c'est pas du tout ça mais ça colle très
bien avec des résultats scientifiques
assez récent sur le muscle alors on
croyait tous moi comme vous jusqu'à il
ya très peu de temps que le muscle 7
juin ils sont deux machines qui nous
fait bouger mais c'est beaucoup beaucoup
plus que ça apparemment chaque fois que
nous contractons nos muscles en effet
libéré des centaines de messages et
c'est comme c'est notre plus grande
glandes endocrines en réalité le muscle
alors chaque fois comme bouge un groupe
musculaire fou en libère tous ces
messages et dont la circulation à qu'est
ce qu'ils font eh bien ils vont agir
soit sur les tissus voisins juste à côté
soit ils sont libérés dans la
circulation et ses messagers sont
essentiels pour l'équilibré du corps et
du cerveau
c'est à dire qu'ils agissent sur le
système circulatoire sur le système
reproductif respiratoires toutes nos
fonctions dépend de ses messagers et en
particulier y en a beaucoup qui joue sur
le système immunitaire qui lui est très
diffus dans le corps et on comprend très
bien à ce moment là pourquoi la manque
d'activité physique pendant plus d'une
heure
ça entraîne un déséquilibre dans le coup
mais dont tous ces systèmes à l'autre et
graduellement très insidieusement
pendant des années à force d'être
déséquilibré régulièrement on entraîne
des états pathologiques mais qui arrive
tellement petit à petit qu'on les voit
pas arriver et à bonjour le médecin
bougies avaient en fait monsieur vous
avez un diabète ou etc etc ou un cancer
ça va jusqu'à la mort subite en voir
comme résultat de l'inactivité
alors il ya une bonne nouvelle et une
mauvaise nouvelle la dedans la bonne
nouvelle c'est une minute ça suffit
c'est génial
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'il faut
quand même le faire toutes les heures
alors sur le lieu de travail
si pas très très très pratique toutes
les heures on va pas évidemment aller
quelque part faut faire des exercices et
d'ailleurs nos employeurs ne vont
peut-être pas tout à fait d'accord parce
que sur le lieu de travail
on est quand même un peu censé
travailler entre les bavardages et les
cafés et c'est donc à pas ajouté de
l'exercice là dessus ne va pas être
forcément bienvenu problème
comment faire il faudrait trouver un
exercice qui non seulement fait bouger
tous les groupes musculaires
régulièrement mais en plus on augmente
la productivité
alors bon est ce qu'il ya une solution
ah c'est là que j'introduis la vedette
de mon histoire
j'ai perdu le sens at il est là la
vedette de mon histoire ce soir
s'appelle le cerib elle m ou alors en
français on dit le cervelet alors vous
voyez c'est ce petit chignon à l'arrière
du cerveau tout en bas et en deux
feuilles le connaître plus parce que
c'est quelque chose que je ne savais pas
moi même jusqu'à ce que je commence à
travailler dessus
c'est que c'est la partie du cerveau qui
a connu la plus grande expansion entre
les autres grands primates et l'homme
alors déjà on se débat quand même ça
doit faire quelque chose dans tous nos
qualités extraordinaires de cerveau d'un
homme connu et en plus de ça le cerveau
le cervelet contient plus de salles hull
que toutes les autres parties du cerveau
réunies y compris ce fameux cortex
préfrontal magnifique dont on se vante
en permanence alors vous connaissiez le
cervelet vous le connaissiez sûrement
pour son rôle dans le mouvement
oui alors il est connu depuis des
décennies parce que quand même on savait
très bien qu'il était très important
dans la coordination des mouvements
comme par exemple vous apprenez à servir
une balle de tennis
ou alors faire un pas de cha cha cha ou
jouer d'un instrument de musique
et bien c'est le cervelet qui est
responsable de la programmation très
fine de tous ces mouvements extrêmement
précis et d'ailleurs si vous vous
rappelez de quand vous avez appris à
conduire un moment assez marquant pour
beaucoup
c'est la première fois qu'on prend le
volant et bien il faut tourner le
veulent on peut passer la vitesse
regarder le rétroviseur voir ce qui se
passe autour
c'est la panique totale et puis au bout
de quelques fois tout ça ça devient
automatique on n'a plus besoin d'y
penser
le juste le fait de prendre le volant et
tout le reste se fait totalement
automatiquement mais ça c'est grâce au
cervelet formidable mais bon ça nous
amène pas beaucoup dans le domaine de
l'intelligence et notre productivité au
travail
mais voilà il y à un neurologue
américain qui s'appelle jérémy chaman à
philadelphie qui un jour se dit c'est
quand même très bizarre parmi ces
patients qui ont subi une lésion dans le
cervelet où l infarctus et au lieu
d'avoir des problèmes de programmation
de leur mouvement
ils ont comme des problèmes de
programmation de l'an penser ou de leurs
émotions ils sont incapables d'aligner
une suite de pensée logique dans une
conversation ou alors ils subissent une
hausse des primes a totalement
guérissable il se dit c'est curieux
comme il est en même temps chercheurs eh
bien ils commencent à regarder de très
près les liens entre le cervelet et le
reste du cerveau est effectivement et
trouve non seulement qu'il ya beaucoup
de liens entre le cervelet et les
réseaux cognitif y compris bien sûr ce
fameux contexte le pack préfrontal et
entre le cervelet et les réseaux
émotionnel avec le système limbique bien
sûr alors déjà très important mais en
plus de ça ils voient que l'architecturé
même du cervelet fait que quand nous
apprenons un nouveau programmation de
mouvement le nouveau réseau qui est créé
dans le cervelet pour gérer cette
automatisation des mouvements émis
automatiquement en lien avec ses autres
réseaux cognitif et émotionnel
donc en fait la programmation de
mouvement les nouveaux mouvements sont
très très lié à notre intelligence et à
nos émotions
alors pour ce qui concerne les émotions
je pense que c'est assez instinctif
d'ailleurs tout le langage du corps est
basé là dessus si vous m'avez vous voyez
arriver sur scène en marchant comme ça
vous êtes assez confiant que je vais
vous faire passer un moment assez
agréable sympathique tandis que si vous
me voyez venir un peu vous appréhendé un
petit peu les 20 minutes que vous allez
passer avec moi donc les émotions on
comprend très bien mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de données sur le fait que le
cervelet est en relation avec les
réseaux cognitifs de l'intelligence
alors quand on réfléchit à toutes ces
données programmation de mouvements
intelligence émotions
ça fait penser à quoi oui bien sûr à la
danse
et quand on réfléchit la danse comme
activité physique on a toujours dansé en
tant qu'être humain
les premières traces date d'il ya 40
millions et en plus quand on regarde les
sociétés parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
culture humaine différente on pourrait
dire notre culture l on est con si dense
comme saab ont d'ailleurs on ne le fait
pas en irlande mais ils n'ont pas ce que
tout le monde entier donc les sociétés
qu'on n'a jamais regardé les gens
dansent et excusez moi je vais juste
prendre petites gorgées d'eau comme
prévu je faisais ici j'ai pas tué tué le
micro
alors la danse on pourrait presque dire
que c'est une fonction biologique et ton
beaucoup de sociétés on attribue
beaucoup de pouvoirs à la danse ont fait
des dons ce pour des besoins
thérapeutiques ou dans des rituels pour
passer d'un âge impubère pubères et
c'est pour des liens sociaux très très
important on fait beaucoup de danse pour
créer du lien ou alors pour les couples
et même dans nos sociétés dites
tellement moderne
quand on a des moments importants de la
vie des fiançailles un mariage un grand
anniversaire la fin d'études
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour fêter ça et
bien on danse tous à un fait croire qu
il y a vraiment quelque chose de
fondamental dans la danse que c'est
presque un besoin biologiques et
physiologiques alors fort de tout ça
alors et le tonga
ah oui oui bien il vient je ne sais pas
combien de temps il me reste il s'en va
tout le temps alors fort de tout ça avec
notre équipe de recherche à l'université
de karting en australie nous avons du
bon ben on va essayer quand même sur le
lieu de travail
quelque chose dans ces minimaliste on va
faire apprendre un pas de danse tous les
jours un groupe de gens et on va voir ce
que ça fait ou sur juste quatre semaines
tous les jours un petit pain donc le
premier jour ils apprennent 1 2 3 4
le deuxième jour ils apprennent à
tourner le troisième jour autre chose et
ainsi de suite
et puis le cinquième jour on les réunit
tous ensemble et on danse la petite
chorégraphie de 4 pas avec la musique
plusieurs fois et ça fait une petite
réunion de fin de semaine on a fait
remplir des questionnaires avant et
après l'étude
et franchement même moi qui suis très
optimiste j'étais tellement sidéré par
les résultats je pensais que personne ne
les croirait et en améliorer les
peter qu'on a regardé de santé physique
de santé mentale mais en bonus en
quelque sorte
il y avait une augmentation de leurs
sentiments de lien avec l'entreprise et
avec les autres participants de l'étude
donc il me semble que la danse est
réellement un moyen pour l'entreprise
spécifiquement d'introduire une nouvelle
façon de faire bouger les gens c'est sûr
que il faut avoir des managers avec une
certaine confiance en eux qu'ils sont
prêts à se mettre avec leurs collègues
et employés sur le même niveau dans un
domaine très limités qui n'a rien à voir
avec le travail ni avec leur vie privée
c'est un domaine privilégié où on peut
créer quelque chose ensemble très
différent et ça a vraiment des effets
sur les émotions immédiate
on n'a pas besoin d'attendre vingt ans
pour le voir c'est immédiat vous voulez
changer l'esprit d'une équipe c'est
comme ça vous me croyez pas vous l'avez
montré vous même tout à l'heure pour la
voter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]